as of 8 33 eastern time
on august 9 2021 andrew cohen was still
the governor of new york
can't promise that's going to last much
longer we're not sure but fox's matt
finn has been on this story and brings
us the very latest now hey matt
tucker brittany kamisso is one of 11
women that have accused governor andrew
cuomo of sexual harassment commisso is
named as
executive assistant number one in the
attorney general's report
and she says while taking a selfie the
governor inappropriately touched her
i then felt while taking the selfie
his hand go down my back onto my butt
and he started rubbing it not sliding it
not you know quickly brushing over it
rubbing my butt kamisso also alleges the
governor gave her hugs that she says
we're not the type he would give his
mother or brother rather the type
seeking sexual satisfaction she says
those hugs
were not normal or welcomed the governor
has denied inappropriately touching
anyone cuomo even released a
reel of himself kissing and hugging
people suggesting it's his normal
behavior
there are growing calls tonight for the
governor to resign even the president
says cuomo should step down
the new york state assembly right now is
conducting an impeachment investigation
its findings could be
released as early as the end of this
month the new york state assembly only
needs a simple majority vote to move
forward with that impeachment trial
tucker
matt finn thanks so much for that thank
you
so andrew cuomo is a weird always butt
rubber terrible governor actually
um but tonight we want to pause from
piling on andrew cuomo which we'll
be happy to resume tomorrow and take a
moment to defend
the chief bodybuilding correspondent
over at cnn
who is his brother we're not going to
show any pictures of chris cuomo flexi
on camera we've done that before
we're just going to note that in the
middle of this scandal that may remove
his brother from office chris cuomo
decided he's been going vacation now we
know what you're thinking could this
really be a vacation
but cnn broke into its extended coverage
of sturgis
to answer that question yes it's a real
vacation
here's their position on his vacation
telling a well-off host to hang out by
the pool for a couple of weeks
is not a real punishment it's bs when
fox sends a host off on
vacation during a scandal scolding a
host in public
saying what they did was inappropriate
that is an actual punishment
chris is going to have a surreal
birthday on monday
he always takes his birth week off he
always takes it off work
but this year he's going to be absent
while his brother is fighting for his
political life
trying to stop this impeachment train
and bad faith actors are gonna say chris
has been cancelled or something
when they don't see him on air on monday
don't believe it
i checked resources on his staff and
they confirmed that he booked this time
off months ago
can that kid be real he's got to be a
plant from msnbc
there's no chance that he's actually
acting on behalf of cnn he's too
discrediting
but anyway we're just playing you the
tape and you can evaluate it for
yourself so this is cnn's position
when one of our anchors takes a vacation
it's totally real
but if you work at fox news all
vacations are potemkin vacations
that was don lamont's position when we
went fishing a couple years ago
tucker carlson is on vacation as of
tonight due back
on the 19th fox news has a long history
of their hosts
heading out on vacation after they
become engulfed in controversy over
inflammatory comments
oh yes don lemon the plane probably flew
into a black hole yeah
for sure to paraphrase sigmund freud
sometimes a vacation
is just a vacation and we're willing to
believe
that chris cuomo's vacation is just a
vacation two other quick things
about chris cuomo in total sincerity one
you're not responsible for the
misbehavior
of your relatives sorry you didn't
choose them in fact you're not
responsible for anyone else's
misbehavior
only your own that's just true it's the
basis of american justice and it's the
basis of human decency don't blame
people for things they didn't do
and the other point to make is chris
cuomo is coming under a lot of fire for
helping his brother in the middle of
this crisis now we can't evaluate how
true that is
but if it is true let's be real for a
second
it's understandable it's his brother
your loyalty
should be to your family above all else
not joking at all
maybe even above your job maybe even
above
jeff zucker if your brother calls and
says
i need help if you don't give him help
because you're pretending to be a news
anchor on some stupid cable channel
nobody watches
you're betraying your brother and that's
a greater sin than any of the dumb
politics they espoused on that channel
totally true so we're not going to
criticize him for that
one more piece of advice chris cuomo
take a break from the girls on vacation
you'll enjoy it better hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis
you will not get it anywhere else